her back with avi Reuben who wrote a
book brave new ballot the battle to
safeguard democracy in the age of
electronic voting avi why did you write
the book and what did you find so I've
been looking at electronic voting now
for several years ever since I did an
analysis with my research team of the
Diebold electronic voting systems and
found serious security problems one of
the things that happened as a result of
that the media was very interested in it
and there started to be a lot of stories
about the security of electronic voting
systems and I found that the vendors
would say something and then I would say
something and we would each get a little
short soundbite and I never had the
opportunity to tell the whole story or
exactly what is wrong with these
machines what can be done about it
what is a better voting system and so
writing the book gave me the opportunity
to really spell it all out what
percentage of the country will use
voting machines this fall so 39 percent
of the voters are going to use
electronic voting but if you look at
electronic voting more broadly and you
include the optical scan systems because
after all even an optical scanner where
you have a paper ballot if it's getting
fed through an optical scan machine
their software on there and so some of
the security concerns with any kind of
software exists there - unfortunately
that is controllable via audit and you
can also have manual recounts when I say
39% I'm referring to fully electronic
systems where you touch a screen in a
particular spot and it tallies the votes
that also includes some of them that are
now being outfitted with printers and
that design has some trade-offs it's not
quite as good as a system where you're
optically scanning the ballots and you
have paper ballots as opposed to a paper
record and that's something that's
important to differentiate between but
you know almost 40% are going to be
voting on these systems and I know I've
had a little experience in this how
accurate are these voting machines you
know the one of the problems really is
that there's no way to know how accurate
they are in an election because in this
country we have a secret ballot so you
can't keep track of who voted for whom
since you don't know who voted for whom
at the end of the day all you have is a
tally and you don't really know whether
it got the right result will be taking
calls in a few minutes if you
like to join this conversation please
dial 737 excuse me - OH - seven 3700 -
if you support Democrats - OH - seven
3700 one if you support President Bush
and 202 6 - 8 0 - 0 5 if you support
others so did you you are a
whistleblower I read and so what did you
learn back in 2003 concerning the
machines accuracy and what like to
examine these issues in the first place
so you know my area of expertise is
computer security and I never signed up
really to be a whistleblower of any kind
but when we looked at the source code
for the Diebold system and I received a
call from a professor at Stanford named
David ill and he told me that the source
code was available on the internet which
is the software that runs these machines
and determines how they operate and when
we found the code was so poorly written
and so many security problems with it I
became concerned when I realized that a
lot of people were actually voting on
these systems and we found things like
errors in the way that they provided
cryptography the encryption of the of
the information in the machines silly
things like the administrator smart card
which is used to administer the machines
had a pin code of 1 1 1 1 so you know
they thought to put a pin code on it but
they made it 1 1 1 1 and things like the
encryption key for all of the machines
being identical which is like having the
same exact lock on every house in
America what where were you working at
the time I was a professor at Johns
Hopkins University where I still am
right now I'm gonna take some calls now
a first call Studio City California on
the Democrats line uh yes hello hi
oh hey caller I am so happy to see you
on this broadcast sir I am I'm so how
can I put this I am so incredibly
frustrated with the fact that our system
has slid to the point that we have
computers counting boats that are built
by privately owned companies that have
decidedly strong political agendas I
personally don't care if one American is
liberal or conservative or right-wing or
left-wing
that does not matter what matters is the
fact that we live in the United States
of America and the only thing that makes
it the United States of America is that
we as citizens have the ability to have
representatives in our government they
work for us and having these electronic
voting machines I think is the final
piece of the puzzle in the corporate
takeover of the United States of America
they own our media there's six companies
that own all of the media in this
country and we get their view we get the
corporate ownership view and they own
the voting machines and I mean just the
cost of a voting machine you look at the
cost of just one of these voting
machines and you put that up again
printing up paper ballots and handing
pencils out to people and having them X
out some boxes and throw them all in a
box and having the people count them and
it's like it's it's ridiculous
hi do you have a question my question is
what the hell can we do about this how
can we stop this I mean the only the
only solution that I see at this point
and I am being completely honest here
i-i-i am not I don't know I just learned
how to do email basically five years ago
so I'm not the person to do this but
it's going to take it's going to take
some person some computer hacker to bust
onto a couple of these networks and just
make it so all the votes go a hundred
percent for some independent caller
let's get an answer to your question
what what can average citizens do to
make sure that these voting machines are
accurate so I think the caller brings up
a lot of interesting questions and there
were several issues in there that I want
to address the first is that I don't
think we're at the point now where you
can have just paper and pencil ballots
and voting
because in your own state of California
right now you may have 40 to 50
different things to put on a ballot
you've got 10 million voters in Los
Angeles counties so if you do the math
that's a whole lot of counting that has
to happen after the election the good
news is that I think we can use
computers for some things that they're
good at without having to entirely trust
them you bring up the point that
corporate America is controlling the
elections well there are designs for
voting systems and I described in my
book how this would how this would be
where you don't have to trust one bit
the people that are building the
election system and I think the gold
standard is to be able to have your
adversary design and build the voting
system and still have a voting system
that they couldn't cheat in and that the
public could still have confidence in
next called Baldwin Missouri on the
independent line yeah my question is
about the regular old Gantt Ron ballots
you know everyone in America knows how
to use these I'm sure every state has
machines that already know how to read
them you might know better than me but I
believe they're mechanical they're not
even programs it seems to me that I mean
you're obviously not going to be able to
stop you know a crooked guy is just
gonna throw out votes but you can at
least you know all these butterfly
ballots people voting for Buchanan and
all this nonsense you know it's easy to
make a standardized ballot that is
accurately read that there's no real
order this is you know old technologies
so maybe worrying if anyone has tried to
do that make scantrons yeah National
ballot sure about 48% of voters are
going to be voting on a system that
optically scans a paper ballot that's a
standardized form like what we used to
fill out for the SATs these systems come
under criticism for two reasons although
I think both of these are things that
can be overcome one of them is that when
people mark these they may make a stray
mark that would completely invalidate
the ballot and in some states the laws
are such that if the the scanner makes
an error or if there's a stray mark it
could spoil the entire voters ballot
another criticism of these things is
that it's not actually mechanical these
systems take power and they have
software and their electrical
and it's possible that they may be
calibrated incorrectly and that could
cause votes to be counted wrong however
both of these can be solved pretty
relatively simply one of the ways to
solve the calibration problem is simply
to audit them and do in some percentage
of the machines manual checks just have
people count the ballots and compare
them to the electronic tally that was
obtained from the optical scanner and if
they match then you you know that you're
okay and as far as the strain marks go
there's a technology on the market
called ballot marking which is kind of a
familiar touchscreen interface except
that these machines don't actually count
the votes so they can't cheat all they
do is take the voter input and then they
print out a marked up ballot that the
voter can look at and determine that
that's how they meant to mark it and
submit it and that system does not allow
for any stray marks and it also prevents
you from over voting where you vote for
too many candidates for an office and
spoil your ballot that way next call
from Fairview Oklahoma on the blind
supporting President Bush yeah I was
just thinking you know this guy come on
with computers is just a great thing
because throughout history people could
you know they've threw out votes or can
add extra votes people can get threw out
votes just as easy as a computer could
so this just makes it a lot easier on
the voters themselves then yeah the
electronic voting is definitely a lot
more user friendly and I agree that
there's always been a long history of
fraud with paper and every other voting
system that we've had but the concern
that I have is that with electronic
voting when you have large amounts of
software on a machine controlling
everything from the voter input to the
final tallies you end up in a situation
where it's very easy to rigged the
election on a grand scale let me give
you an example let's say that I work for
one of the manufacturers and I have
particular partisan views I could
program the software so that it flips
votes from the candidates that I don't
like to the candidates that I do like
that software gets put into tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of different machines and that malicious
activity takes place everywhere whereas
with more traditional and older pay
kind of voting that you're referring to
if you want to commit fraud you have to
go somewhere and commit a certain amount
what we call retail fraud as opposed to
wholesale fraud next call from Allenton
Allentown Pennsylvania on the Democrats
line yeah good morning I want to talk
about vote on every topic for American
people with everything in the local
government would be great if we can do
it securely like we clear with taxes
then we can fix a lot of problems that
we have in our country that's why you
have to say thank you for c-span okay um
yeah I don't I don't think that's a
question about the technology itself but
rather whether or not we want to have
direct democracy and having people
voting on issues next line next call on
the bush line supporting President Bush
Indianapolis Indiana yes I just want to
say I mean it is for somebody like me
who just came to this country and who
cherish democracy is so much because of
my for my experience it is very
surprising to me that this is not an
urgent issue the question I want to ask
you is why based on what you have said
it seemed as if there was a solution out
there for this problem where's the
resistance coming from you know it can
be adopt what you are afraid and that is
an excellent question and one that keeps
me up at night the resistance that I've
encountered has come from several places
the vendors have billions of dollars to
spend on promoting their views and
selling the products that they currently
have in stock that they've made we also
have election officials who have gone
out on a limb got a lot of publicity for
the fact that they were groundbreaking
in their advances and technologies and
moving to electronic voting all of a
sudden you have computer scientists and
others saying that these systems are not
secure enough and these people don't
want to admit that they made in some
instances a hundred million dollar
mistake and so they're putting up
resistance I also think that it's
somewhat natural for people who aren't
that familiar with security and with the
potential
security problems too want to try to
automate a system just the way we
automate everything else we have air
travel and gaming and banking everything
is done online and with computers we've
got the iPad generation and so why not
vote on computers that will be much more
efficient and user-friendly
unfortunately we have to take a step
back and make sure we get the security
right and then we can see how can
technology help us without compromising
security next call Cottonwood Arizona on
the independent line hi I on c-span -
there's been several people who have
written books about the Ohio election
the president so do you what do you
think about that is it's not a
conspiracy you know what I think Thank
You Colin so what I think about the
lessons from Ohio are that it's very
very important for us to have election
systems that are transparent that the
public can understand what went on as
far as the technology goes that if we're
going to have recounts they can be
publicly observable that every step in
the process is something that the public
can understand how it works and rather
than dwelling on whether or not the last
election was stolen I think we should
focus all of our energy on making sure
that regardless of what happens in the
next election the voters and the public
will know that it was the right thing
that should have happened and if it
seems that it's not there'll be a way to
recover and recount and figure out what
really needs to happen without a
tangible record of every voters intent
there's really no way to recover at the
end and we're left with all of these
doubts and we're going to get calls like
this for years saying do you think the
last election was stolen and I'd like to
have the questions change and say you
know isn't it too bad that the last
election came out this way or that way
rather than was the election stolen next
call Columbia South Carolina on the line
supporting President Bush good morning I
find it ironic that you go to court and
Sue because you don't want to people
heaven to show IDs Africa and Mexico
just had elections where they had to
show IDs you know Bobby Kennedy jr. he
always says elections were stolen the
last two were I think his family won
elections president and other elections
by state
and one other thing the ABC movie well
conservatives have always been maligned
and now they got a movie maybe making
Democrats look kind of bad and now you
do its wanna sue over this to keep the
movie I mean you got to look at both
sides of the picture if you're going
after one what movie are you referring
to your color oh call it we lost them
I'm not sure what the question was I'm
not sure either let's go to the next
call from Miami Florida on a Democrat
line hello how are you good morning good
morning you know I'm very upset and
disturbed about the Machine of boating I
tell you truth I'm American I really
wanted to vote this last time there was
so many people in mind and these
machines it's just a you know in other
words in Miami one time this last
election they said they had 50,000 votes
deleted and some of the people in Fort
Lauderdale they'll take home the boxes
so there's so much fraud going on with
with these machines I will never vote in
America as long as I live the sensitive
issue in Miami yeah I I think it's it's
a real shame if this issue causes people
not to vote I encourage everybody who's
eligible to vote to vote and if you
don't like the equipment and if you
don't like the process of the system
then do what you can to try to change it
vote join an activist organization or
write to your representatives but I
think that the one way to guarantee that
your vote will not be counted is not to
cast it next call from Naples Florida on
the line supporting President Bush good
morning morning you know it's
interesting we just had the primaries
here in Florida on Tuesday and I happen
to be a clerk in a precinct I've gone
through all the voting requirements the
machines the background the sensitivity
training everything you need to do I've
looked at how the machines are set up
I've read things on how the machines are
set up I want to know why someone hasn't
shown up on 60 minutes yet to confirm
all what all you can spare or say that
somebody's rigging elections first of
all you've got
have a lot of people that would know
what to do if I was a supervisor of
elections all that I got to do is hold
one machine back cast votes that same
day so if somebody couldn't say the
programmers did it cast votes that same
day on that machine see if there's any
discrepancy on that machine it's never
going to put into the system first of
all our votes our quadruple recorded
there's three checks from the machine
that record the votes for redundancy
there's now a chip that comes out of the
machine so in other words it can't be
tampered with between the Machine and
the collection of the machines we take
and do that through a secure line it's
transmitted by modem unsecured line you
don't know when we're gonna do it
because if I'm slow and getting my votes
counted getting the machine set up or
taken down or whatever you don't know if
I'm gonna call in between 742 and 830
keen you don't know I'm on line for
maybe 15 to 18 seconds tops tell me how
come he's gonna break into that 5000 and
be off the air well first of all I want
to thank the caller for his involvement
in the election process
I myself volunteer as the poll worker in
Maryland and I think it's important to
have as many people support this process
as possible my area of expertise and
research that I've been performing for
many years as computer security and I've
analyzed the d-ball voting machine and
I've looked at many other systems as
well and and my opinion is different my
opinion is that these machines are
insecure that if whoever built them
wanted to rig them that they would be
perfectly capable of doing so and that
the machines would be able to pass all
the testing that the states are doing
and still be rigged you know most of the
states test these machines by just
running a hundred votes through them so
just a trivial example if you have your
system set up so that it performs the
first hundred votes accurately and then
start switching votes or just switches
some votes at the end of the day if
there are more than 100 votes cast
you're going to pass all the tests and
that's just an example but the tests are
hardly at all going to deal with the
kind of fraud that that could exist if
somebody were to cleverly rigged the
software on these machines but even if
it if it wasn't rigged by someone you
know if you work with computers a lot
and software you know that it's very
complex
the DeBolt system has 50,000 lines of
code running on ten million lines of
Windows code and there are many bugs in
there by
virtue of the fact that there are many
lines of code there going to be many
many bugs and one of those bugs could
cause the voting machine in all three
redundant locations to get the wrong
answer and that's why I think that it's
important to have something like a voter
verified paper record and preferably a
voter verified paper ballot in fact mr.
Rubin this is already happening some of
the proof of some of the problems in a
recent Bloomberg article it says in
Arkansas officials in st. Francis County
undertook a recount that overturned
results in the June state Senate run off
after ballot programming errors in
nearby Phillips County a machine failed
to count more than 400 votes in Pulaski
County officials were not unable to
report the results of a May 23rd primary
until a recount was finished 14 days
after the election because of software
malfunctions and problems in programming
is it similar to what some of the things
that you found some of the error rates
absolutely you know when I when I was
coming out with the book my publisher
asked me to come up with an epigraph to
start each chapter that would describe a
particular problem that occurred that
actually occurred with electronic voting
systems and what I did was I searched
for news articles but I only had 22
chapters and I had so many examples that
I had to pick and choose which are the
ones that I wanted to use I guess let's
take another call now the next call is
Orono Maine on the independent line good
morning my question is quite simple I'm
just trying to figure out if there was a
good way of counting them why we
couldn't vote by telephone using a
social security number and a PIN number
because a lot of people can't get out of
the voting machines and it's really
difficult for a lot of the lower-income
people actually to get out and in a
really busy schedule I'm wondering if
it's any kind of a real idea that you
could use a telephone with a pin number
and their social security number even if
they know who you're voting for it
really doesn't even matter that's
realistic to you voting by telephone I
don't think so you know one of the most
important fundamental parts of our
voting in the United States is this
right to a private ballot the idea that
even your spouse or your boss can't know
how you voted gives you a lot of freedom
because if you're voting by phone you
could be coerced by someone to vote a
certain way or you can even imagine
in a very densely populated area
somebody coming around with $10 bills
and a cellphone and paying people to
vote a certain way so I'd rather not see
us get away from the sanctity of the the
polling station and the private voting
booth and I think it you know if we're
going to compromise on voter privacy
than you know just open up the Internet
and at the end of the election publish
how everyone voted and then we'll all
know this problem becomes very easy it's
really the requirement for voter privacy
that makes it a hard problem last call
from Zimmerman Minnesota on the line
supporting President Bush this as a
foundation is the the United States is
based on a representative Republic form
of government not a democracy and the
founding fathers said that the
difference between a democracy and a
representative Republic is the
foundation of a democracy is based on
emotion and the foundation of
Representative Republic is on the rule
of law and it was very interesting for
me to see that what happened in Florida
is people riled up the emotion while the
more carried out its rule and that
happened well this is interesting to me
because what your heaviness people are
wanting to rile up the emotions and as a
representative Republic every time
there's something that goes wrong
there's a law that tells you to do what
what is right my question is why do the
Democrats always don't want you to have
a photo ID and to be able to make things
let you can base on rule instead of on
the emotion okay well I'm going to
answer that
probably a little a little differently
than you were hoping and I just want to
point out that we can see from a lot of
the calls that came in today that people
on both sides of the aisle are very
worked up and very and care very deeply
about elections and about making sure
that their side gets a fair shake and
the best way to do that is to have a
secure accurate reliable transparent and
recoverable auditable and many other
bulls voting system and that is one of
the reasons why I'm pushing very hard
for for having paper ballots well has to
be the final word thank you so much for
coming mr. Rubin thanks a lot tomorrow
we will return with Washington Journal
7:00 a.m. as always have a good day